My heart skips, skips, skips, skips, skips, skips, skips, skips, ö, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, i, Mario, Herzog, Tizzo. Fremde, meine Haufen, hallo, herzlich willkommen, gegenüber von mir sitzt, wie könnte es anders sein? Ja. Ich kann mir sehr viel anderes vorstellen, aber man sagt es so, wo Florent hin will. Danke, schön, du sitzt auch, wir beide sitzen. Wir beide sitzen, nicht, nicht, dass ihr, weil da kamen viele Mails, wie muss man sich eigentlich eure Aufnahmesituation vorstellen? Genau. Steht ihr, liegt ihr, wir lagen lange. Richtig, wir haben uns lange hingelegt, Rücken an Rücken tatsächlich lagen wir. Ja, Folge 12 bis ich glaube 24 haben wir so tatsächlich an Rücken an Rücken gelegen. Wir sind beide Seitenaufnehmer und dachten uns dann, okay, wenn wir uns die ganze Folge anschauen, dann ist das natürlich mit dem Bluthaushalt, das ganze Blut läuft in die linke Gehirnhälfte und dann wird es sehr emotional. Und das wollen wir nicht, das wollten wir von Anfang an nicht, es sollte ein unemotionaler Podcast werden. Ein rationaler, berechnender, vernunftorientierender, ehrgeiziger Podcast. Richtig, und deswegen haben wir gesagt, Rücken an Rücken. Es gibt aber manche Folgen, da hört man, wann wir uns wenden. Und ab dann schauen wir uns an, und dann könnt ihr mal überprüfen, ob ihr den Punkt in den alten Podcast-Ufo-Folgen findet, ab dem wir uns anschauen und was das überhaupt mit uns macht. Aber jetzt stellt euch das Wenden nicht falsch vor, sondern wir sind immer noch, dass das Blut in die rechte Gehirnhälfte fließt, immer noch, aber so wie so zwei Flundern an Land. Wir liegen immer noch Rücken an Rücken, aber wir haben uns sozusagen 180 Grad nach oben gedreht, wie so ein Scharnier. Genau, stell dir das vor, so um die Achse gedreht, aber nicht, dass die Folge emotional wird, ohne Grund, weil das wollen wir nicht, dafür gibt es andere Podcasts. Bei deinen Top-5-emotionalen Podcasts.
Frühling im Bauch natürlich, einer der schönsten Podcasts. Muttergefühle. Muttergefühle, ja. Angst im Dunkeln. Genau. Angst im Hellen. Angst in Höhen gibt es auch sehr viel, wo Leute, die Höhenangst haben, bewusst die Höhe suchen und dort einen Podcast machen. Wir hören mal kurz rein. Und das finde ich ist immer ganz schön, um auch zu reflektieren, was Emotionen überhaupt sind in unserem Leben. Das ist die Frage? Das ist die Frage. Da fangen die an. Was ist Emotion? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Emotionen und Gefühlen? Ist es das Gleiche? All das könnt ihr uns vielleicht verraten, Samuel Linuskowitsch, der dieses herrliche Intro performt. Samuel Linuskowitsch. Linuskowitsch, ein Name? Normaler Einmensch hat zwei Namen, deswegen würde ich sagen, jetzt ein Mensch, zwei Namen. Also Karl Marx kann auch immer zwei Leute gewesen sein. Wie viele Nachnamen hat er? Ein, Linuskowitsch. Ich glaube, Kovic ist sowas wie der Neffe von, so wie Magnusson, der Sohn von und Linus Kovic, du hast ja so Namen, wo das immer ähnlich endet, Jogashvili, das ist ja dann irgendeine Endung, aber man weiss nicht genau, was es ist, aber es endet immer gleich. Willi ist wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie irgendein guter Kumpel, ja, dessen Neffe, ja, Neffen desse.
Okay, finde ich ganz gut. Ich habe gerade gedacht, wo du meintest, was sind Gefühle, und da habe ich mir vorgestellt, was wenn ein Gefühls-Podcast so anfängt, aber das ist eigentlich ziemlich genau das Problem, was ich oft habe bei so Dokumentationen, dass die viel zu früh anfangen oder zu spät. Also entweder setzen sie zu viel voraus, gibt es aber eigentlich nicht. Es gibt nicht diese, ähm, sagen wir mal Nerd-Sender, Gott spricht zu uns, um 23 nach. Na gut, er hat gesagt, ja, ich hab das ja alles geschaffen. Aber hör mal, 23 nach gehen jetzt die Glocken an. Hat Pater Minosterus wieder überzogen oder was? Hat Pater Noster gesagt, so, jetzt werden die Glocken an. Das Q&A in der Heiligen Messer hat wieder zu lange gedauert. Ich habe eine Frage zum brennenden Busch. Komm, schmeiß die Glocken an. Schmeiß die Glocken an. Jetzt müssen wir leider aufhören. Gott hat gesprochen leider. Aber weisst du, was ich meine? Also so ein Sweet Spot für, ich habe schon ein bisschen Wissen über das Thema. Ja. Also so, ich gucke eine, ich gucke eine, muss ich lauter reden oder hört oder hört ihr die Glocken gar nicht, weil die beiden haben mega rein. Ich glaube, es ist ein gängiger Running Gag, dass die Zuhörer die Glocken überhaupt gar nicht hören und sich immer fragen, warum reden sie jetzt so laut, warum alle eine Stunde, warum reden sie eine Runde, warum versuchen sie irgendwas zu übertönen, warum reden sie über Gott, reden lauter und schreien sich an und lachen. Also so muss Jesus sich die ganze Zeit gefühlt haben. Du hast ständig dieses Gott im Ohr, Papa und so, ja nein, ich wollte den Wein... Ja, immer laut. Also, mir fehlt ein Sweet Spot von, äh, ich weiß schon was, weil wenn ich mir eine Dokumentation angaue, über das Sonnensystem, dann, ja, was sind Planeten überhaupt? Man denkt so, Leute, und dann skip, skip, skip, skip, skip. Skip a beat. Genau, dann skippen sie, skippe ich ganz viel und dann sind sie irgendwann bei, ah okay, jetzt erklären sie, Jupiter ist die Grösste, ja, weiss ich alles. Also es ist so schwer für mich, mich dann an einem Punkt weiterzubilden. Ja, es ist schwer. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, die ganzen Arte, kurz gesagt, das ist schon ein bisschen vielleicht nerdiger, aber so, das ist alles so, es geht nicht über einen gewissen Punkt hinaus.
Ich meine, wir haben ein umfangreiches Schulsystem, in dem Leute in Schubladen geworfen werden, gezwängt werden, gesperrt werden. Es gibt in der Sprache B1, B5, B6 verschiedene Sprachen. Ich glaube, man braucht mehr Kategorisierungen. Sind wir bei Büstenhaltergrössen oder sind wir noch bei … Das kann sein, ich weiss es nicht. B16. Man braucht verschiedene Kategorisierungen und dann gibt es auch in der ARD-Mediathek, kannst du dir die Doku genau nach deinem Wissensstand aussuchen eigentlich. Ich bin generell, ich schaue ja gerade Olympia auch voller, voller, voller Langeweile. und was ich da ja immer gut finde sind so Gewichtsklassen und so dass du sagst es ist fair und du darfst nur so viel wiegen und du darfst nur so stark sein, so weit Wurf, nur für die, die bis 20 Meter werfen können, andere nicht, dann gibt es 20 bis 30 Meter weit Wurf und so. Und das finde ich immer gut, dass man da so Kategorien hat, damit es fair bleibt. Manchmal sind es natürlich auch ein bisschen viele Kategorien und man denkt sich, kann man da nicht was zusammenlegen, aber ich fand die Idee von Kategorien generell sehr gut. Zum Beispiel auch, klassisches Ding, ich habe letztens überlegt, ob ich einen Kuchen irgendwo mitbringen soll. Weil die Person meinte, ja, sie mag eine Art von Kuchen besonders gerne. Moment, was war das für ein Gespräch? Es ist allgemein bekannt, dass diese Person eine Kuchenvorliebe hat. Das ist wirklich, wenn du die Person googelst, das erste Autocomplete ist sofort Bienenstich. Wie heißt nochmal dieser Streamer, dieser problematische Streamer? Ich weiss gar nicht, ob der das mittlerweile nicht bereut, sich Kuchen genannt zu haben, weil der ständig, ich mag eigentlich gar nicht so viel Kuchen. Ich mag das eigentlich gar nicht. Das ist auch so, es gibt einen Age of Empires Streamer namens Neely und der hat sein ganzes Streaming Setup und alles rund um Nilpferde designt. Ja, und es gibt da Nilpferd ist sein Logo und so und er heisst Neely und alles Nilpferd. Und in seinem Twitch-Chat kommt immer wieder die Frage auf, why do you love Hippos so much? Und er nur, I don't. Er streamt weiter, weil die Frage ihn mittlerweile so nervt. I don't, I hate it. It's just some animal. So, jetzt muss ich hier die Bogenschützen bauen und hier die Burg angreifen und das ist einfach so herrlich, weil er hat sich selber in dieses ganze, in diese Welt gekleidet, aber hasst es. Und so ist es bei KuchenTV vielleicht auch. Ja, hasst es. Eigentlich, ich bin eher so der Brioche, also so eine herrliche, so eine herrliche Qu Madelands, ja. Madelands TV war damals leider schon belegt. Madelands TV klingt auch nach was anderem. Das stimmt, ja. Es klingt sanfter tatsächlich auch. Kuchen, Kuchen hat auch Q und CH hat auch was Hartes. Ich muss sagen, Kuchen finde ich schon kein schönes Wort. Ich mag es nicht so gern, dieses dieses Kaffeekuchen, wie nehme ich das in Abneigung, genau wie das Wort Teilchen. Teilchen, ja, so ein Stückchen. Und dann machen wir Kaffeekuchen und man hat dann schon diesen Kaffeegeruch so mit drin. Ich bin aber auch kein Kuchen-Fan, aber da können wir drüber reden. Vor allem, es hat sowas von Physik auch, so Teilchen. Es ist dann so, bring mal irgendein Teilchen mit oder so. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie wir es nennen sollen. Es ist ein Teil, aber es ist auch klein. Es ist auch süss. Es ist Teilchen. Da ist im Wenn-Diagramm Konditoren und Physiker, die sich einmal überschneiden in ... Wir haben jetzt nicht so richtig den Namen dafür. Das wäre in Folge 12, hätten wir das als Tweet abgesetzt. Wirklich. Da hätten wir jetzt wahrscheinlich 50 Minuten lang gegoogelt, Venn-Diagram-Generator. Zern, Konditor, was haben wir? Zern, Konditor, dann dieses Handschlag-Emoji, Teilchen. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, kann sehr man noch. Oder Zern, rennender Konditor, Teilchenbeschleuniger. So, guck mal, jetzt haben wir es doch. Das war damals die Twitter-Pipeline, die damals im Jahre 2018 noch wirklich auf Hochtouren lief, wo das wirklich rausgefeuert wurde. Habe ich jetzt gelöscht, ich habe jetzt meinen Twitter-Account gelöscht. Nein, wirklich, mit allen Likes und von all deinen Bekanntschaften und allen Infos, all deine herrlichen Tweets, damit du sie jetzt nochmal im Podcast machen kannst. Ja, damit ich jetzt bei Threads raushauen kann oder im Podcast, genau. Top drei der Stefan-Tweets, an die ich mich erinnere, top drei hier ein Tweet für meine blinden Follower und dann so Punkte wie bei Blindenschrift. Genau, Lautschrift, ja. Und dann hast du zweimal auf meine Tweets geantwortet mit Haha, das fand ich ganz gut. Okay, kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern. Haha, sieben von zehn fand ich immer, fand ich ganz gut. Ja, unvergessen unsere Zeit, wo wir beim Neo-Magazin angestellt waren als Autoren und eigentlich uns Tweets für unsere Twitter- Teilnehmern überlegt haben. Ja, wir immer Gags geklaut haben und dann für uns selbst gemacht haben. Du musst dir das vorstellen, es war für mich immer so ein, im Hintergrund war so ein Grundrauschen und dann sassen da die grossen AutorenInnen zusammen und wir beide eigentlich nur ins Nichts gestarrt und überlegt, was können wir an Tüger aussehen. Tiger, Tiger haben Streifen, Streifenwagen, Tiger in einem Polizeiauto, Streifenwagen, Zebrastreifen, und dann so, Eureka, Eureka! Und dann kam Blindenschrift. Na, war schon gut. Da muss ich noch mal gucken. Aber auf jeden Fall zurück zu dem Kuchen. Ich finde das so nervig, diese Glocken. Das ist auch, ist das ein Alarm irgendwann? Ist es der Highland kehrt zurück oder was? War es früher nicht so, dass Glocken die Stadt gewarnt haben vor einem Meteoriteneinschlag? Nein, aber so sagen wir mal. Ich glaube schon. Also, herzlich willkommen als Glöckner. Ja. Sie sind der neue Glöckner von Köln. Ja. Es gibt eigentlich nur drei Knöpfe. Okay, zeige mir die Knöpfe. Ja, es gibt eigentlich nur drei Knöpfe. Okay. Das ist der Knopf, einfach jede Stunde einmal drücken. Stunde? Jede Stunde, das ist der Knopf für die Heilige Messe. Heißt Stunde einmal drücken und er weiss automatisch, es ist acht Uhr. Nein, nein, sie müssen ja durchgehend in diesem Turm leben, deswegen. Ich weiss. Ja, die Öffentlichkeit darf sie nicht sehen. Ist das Teil des Jobs? Das ist Teil des Jobs tatsächlich. Sie wurde durch einen sehr, sehr langen Auswahlprozess festgelegt, als Person, die man am meisten verstecken muss in dieser Gesellschaft.
Ich will auch nicht gesehen werden.
Das passt doch, wunderbar.
Sehen Sie den Buckel?
Richtig, ja, ja, der ist nicht zu übersehen. Zweiter Knopf zur Heiligen Messe, einfach schön sonntags zehn Uhr drauf, kein Problem. Und der dritte Knopf, Notfälle, darunter fällt Heilandkehr zurück, Apokalypse, Meteorit, die Belagerung, die Stadt wird belagert, sowas in der Ecke. Ich muss den Himmel anstarren. Sie müssen den Himmel anstarren, völlig richtig. Frühwarnsystem. Frühwarnsystem und dann schmeißt die Glocken an und dann haben die Menschen noch die Möglichkeit, noch ihre Katze aus dem Ruhigen, ihre Erdlöcher, sich ein Erdloch zu graben und dort zu leben.
Denn das ist das Ding mit den Meteoriten, die Astrophysik ist so weit, dass wir den Meteoriten ungefähr 160 Jahre, bevor er einschlägt, sehen.
Und dann müssen aber trotzdem alle panisch rumlaufen, ihre Katzen und Hunde packen, ins Erdloch gehen, um dort 160 Jahre lang zu leben.
Super.
Ja, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es früher, die Stadt wird angegriffen, schmeißt die G die glocken an alle gucken auf die uhr auf ihre sonnenuhr halten die so bauen die schnell auf halten das handgelenk wo eine kleine sonnenuhr drauf ist hoch sehen ist es noch nicht ist es nicht die volle stunde es ist 11 uhr 23 warum glocken die leute glocken die leuten ja in der tat wir werden angegriffen,, draußen kommen die Etrusker, stehen vor des Stadtes Tore, wir gehen mal lieber rein ins Erdloch. Um zu sterben. Jetzt gilt es zu sterben. Sterben. Aber so war es doch wahrscheinlich. Im Grunde war es so, es gibt ja auch in Game of Thrones diese legendäre, sehr unbeliebte Szene, die letzte Staffel von Game of Thrones ist ja sehr allgemein verhasst. Und da gab es dann auch eine Szene, wo das wichtiger Plottpunkt war, dass wenn die Glocken geläutet werden, dass die Stadt dann aufgibt. Und das gab auch einen riesen Aufschrei, weil das, anscheinend ist das nicht so. Ja, jetzt sind Drachen ja auch nicht so. Ja, das stimmt. Da hast du natürlich jetzt die ganze Serie ruiniert.
Ein Kumpel hat mal gesagt, Birdman, den Film mag ich nicht, weil er fliegt ja dann irgendwann. Ist ja unrealistisch. Und da habe ich gedacht, ja, okay, jetzt muss ich quasi meinen ganzen Filmgeschmack nochmal umschreiben auf, geht das denn überhaupt? Ja, ich habe ein Physikerfreund von mir hat auch erzählt, dass er auf so einer Konferenz war, wo, ja, klar, ähm, wo es zum Zeitpunkt als Star Wars Episode 7 rauskam und da meinte der Professor meinte, ich hab den Film noch nicht gesehen, aber ich hab's mal durchgerechnet und das geht nicht.
Wir sind jetzt bei sechs.
Hä?
Wir haben es doch nicht durchgerechnet, weil, äh, ich hab. Weil, ich hab's mal durchgerechnet und es geht nicht. Wasser? War so, ja. Na gut, hat mal den Taschenrechner angeworfen. Es ging um die Szene, als diese Raumstation eine Sonne absorbiert, um dann zu schießen zu können. Und das hat er mal durchgerechnet? Und das hat er mal durchgerechnet und er meinte, nee, das müsste sich mit Überlichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen, und deswegen geht das nicht. Und damit hatte sich der Film dann auch erledigt. J.J. Abrams mit gesenktem Haum gibt sich geschlagen, gibt auf, legt den Regiestuhl nieder, Ende. Das geht so nicht. Er hat sich verrechnet. Er hat sich leider verrechnet. J.J. Emelie, wirklich was? Ich habe das doch komplett durchgerechnet mit der Masse eines Sterns, der aufgesaugt wird.
Irgendwie habe ich neulich was gesehen. Einstein meinte, sich verrechnet zu haben.
Er wurde irgendwann mal gefragt, was war denn sein grösster, ja, sein schamvollster Moment, sein schlimmster Tag im Office. Und er geht es um die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass Und jetzt kam raus, dass er sich da gar nicht verrechnet hat. Jetzt, so vor ein paar Jahren, weiß ich nicht, Sternchen, plus minus zehn Prozent, kam raus, ah nee, das ist völlig im Bereich des Möglichen. Und das ist natürlich genial. Das ist schon krass. Also er ist so weit über uns, dass er, selbst wo er denkt, er hätte Fehler gemacht, hat er eigentlich keine Fehler gemacht. Seine Intuition war nicht richtig. Sein Fehler ist immer noch besser als unsere beste Leistung. Wir können das noch nicht mal, wir kommen da noch nicht mal rein. Sein größter Fehler war zu sagen, er hat einen Fehler gemacht. Aber ja, eigentlich auch nicht, weil es wieder auf seinen Mythos einzahlt. Also eigentlich, er macht alles richtig. Es gibt ja diesen Mythos, dass er gar nicht so gut in Mathe war, ne, und dann stimmt aber auch nicht anscheinend. Bin ich, also bin ich auch nicht. Ich auch nicht. Bin auch nicht so gut in Mathe. Stimmt, das ist im Vorspann von Schloss Einstein. Ja? Ach so. Einstein hatte in Mathe nur eine vier. Ja, genau. Einstein hatte nur eine vier in Mathe, wäre die lyrische, hatte in Mathe nur eine vier, ist das nicht die lyrische. Aber es reimt sich dann auf Mathe? Einstein hatte nur eine vier in Mathe und war später mal total genial denn alles ist alles ist einstein schluss einstein hast du das gesehen früher tatsächlich nie ich auch nicht so aber da waren noch ganz viele leute die jetzt große stars sind oder so so nina chuba mässig oder ist das was anderes verwechsle ich das weiß nicht hört genau mein Wissen Schlagertig auf. Ich dachte immer, der Reiz ist, dass man sich das jetzt noch mal anguckt und sagt, ah, das ist ja der von Seed und das ist ja Crow und das ist irgendwie Mark Medlock und so. Und so nochmal rückblickend, die alle Seed, weisst ihr da am Ende dann doch alle? Mark Medlock? Oder ich weiss auch nicht mehr, wie die. Was macht der? Die die die alle da zusammengekommen sind oder so. Manchmal haust du so Promis raus
von vor
weiss nicht, die waren so, da merkt man
genau, ab wann du aufgehört hast, mit den
öffentlichen, mit den bunten Themen.
Bevor ich ins Kloster gegangen bin, bevor ich
mich komplett entzogen habe der Unterhaltung, im allgemeinen
Spaßverbot, habe
ich tatsächlich noch mein letztes Album, das ich mir gekauft habe, war Mark Madlock. Ich habe ihn aber für den Detektiv gehalten. Er lebt als Privatier auf Sylt. Ich wäre auch gern Privatier. Einfach Privat. Was machen Sie beruflich? Privat. Privatier. Die Definition ist so viel Geld haben, dass man sich zurückgezogen irgendwo leben kann, oder? Geil. Oder? Einfach privat. Du hast keinen beruflichen Kontext mehr, es ist alles privat. So egal wo du bist, reisen sie beruflich oder privat. Privat. Alles privat, da müssen wir mich gar nicht fragen. Immer privat. In Deutschland gibt es im Jahr 2021 rund 809.000 Privatiers.
Okay. 809.000? Krass, dass das immer so eine runde Zahl ist.
Siehe auch Frugalist, Pensionär, Rentier, Zeitwohlstand. Rentier ist eine Person, die von regelmäßigen Zahlungen aus in Aktien oder Anleihen angelegtem Kapital, der Vermietung von Immobilien oder der Verpachtung von Land lebt. Ein Rentier. Nicht zu verwechseln mit Privatier. Der Privatier hat ja, wie gesagt, nur private, also hat privat so viel Geld, dass er davon leben kann und keine Erwerbstätigkeit mehr ausführt. Und warum Rentier? Also ist das so, sind die vom Weihnachtsmann so gut bezahlt, dass die einfach komplett nur in Aktien bezahlt werden, dass die davon leben können? Oder woher kommt die Idee Rentier? Das kann ich nicht, das ist unmöglich herausfinden. Reicht das gerne mal nach, falls ihr Rentiere seid. Also wir haben ja bestimmt in unserer Zuhörerschaft auch das eine oder andere Rentier nach dieser Definition. Schickt uns gerne mal ein Bild von euch, bitte mit Nase auch zu sehen. Und wichtig ist, erklärt uns, warum ihr Rentiere seid und wie wir es schaffen, Rentiere zu werden. Genau.
Super spannend, okay.
Nee, wie gesagt, also Mark Medlock, deine ganzen Referenzen,
mit denen du um dich schlägst, sind wahrscheinlich Privatese.
Aber also Mark Medlock hat dann in seiner Zeit auf dem Zenit genug Geld verdient,
um komplett sich zurückziehen zu können, oder was?
Genau, genug Geld hat er geschafft.
Immer noch husten, ne?
Wahnsinn. Schon immer noch husten. Du bist immer noch krank. Nee, krank will ich jetzt nicht sagen. Du hast jetzt einfach so einen Dauerkrank zustande, oder was? Das ist einfach keine langfristige, auch meine Podcast-Karriere kann dir ja nerven, stören. Kann ja den Bach runtergehen, ja. Das ist natürlich auch im Sommer so diese Klimaanlagengeschichte. Ich glaube, wir werden da noch große Probleme kriegen. Ich bin ja damals in New York richtig krank geworden, weil diese ständige superheiss auf der Strasse, superkalt in Räumen hat mich komplett fertig gemacht. Der Mensch ist dafür nicht gebaut. Das ist ständig diese kalte Luft und ich glaube, Klimaanlagen werden uns noch komplett in den Ruin treiben. Ja, ich überlege auch eine Klimaanlage, mir jetzt reinzuballern, weil ich halte es nicht aus. Ich kann nicht schlafen mehr, weil es ist zu heiß da, wo ich schlafe. Ich habe gehört, die meiste Temperaturregulierung geht über den Kopf. Das heißt, wenn du dir den kalten Hut aufsetzt, dann hast du deinen Körper schon beidesgehend reguliert. Ich dachte, die wahre sportliche Leistung passiert im Kopf. So ist es gemeint. Nein, nein. Also. Also so mental. Nee, nee, es reicht. Du musst nur den Kopf kühlen und dann ist dein ganzer Körper kühl, sozusagen. Das ist die Idee. Das heißt, diese Hüte mit diesem Ventilator vorne drin waren genau richtig. Die waren genau historisch, wissenschaftlich auf genau dem richtigen Weg, sahen nur leider dumm aus. Das ist oft ja das Problem, dass genau der richtige, leider unser ästhetisches Verständnis mit dem naturwissenschaftlichen Effizienzgedanken leider nicht zusammenpasst. Ah, aber das ist total machbar. Funktioniert leider nicht. Weil wir so alle denken, T-Shirt, kurze Hose, coole Sneaks, Top-Down-Sneaks, so. Aber nein, du brauchst diesen Hut mit den Ventilatoren, der dir konstant Wind in die Augen bläst. Das ist eigentlich genau richtig. Ja, was ich ja mal überlegt habe zu machen, das meine ich jetzt ganz im Ernst. Ich brauche da irgendwie Investorenhilfe, ich brauche Rentiere und Privatiers. Und Privatiers mit Rentieren, dem Tier. Weil ich hatte überlegt nach Dune. Ich habe Dune gesehen und Dune wurde ja ganz lustig als Balenciaga Star Wars bezeichnet. Ja. Was ich lustig finde, weil es sieht auch so einfach so aus. Ästhetisch ist es ein Balenciaga Star Wars. Du hast nicht diese Patina, die du hast bei R2D2, wo dann irgendwie auch mal Rost rauskommt oder so, oder wenn du den alten, den Millennium-Falken siehst, so, sieht alles sehr funktional und so aus. Schäbig. Schäbig, genau. Was ja auch irgendwie den Reiz ausmacht. Ja. Und es passt zu diesem Anfangssatz vor langer, langer Zeit in einer weitweiten Fangenalaxis. Und keine Geländer. Es ist eben nicht Zukunft, sondern Vergangenheit, es ist irgendwie so eine behauptete Geschichte. Sehr schön. Und keine Geländer. Keine Geländer. In Star Wars gibt es nirgendwo Geländer. Es gibt keine Sicherheitsgedanken. Es sind immer riesige Hochstädte mit irgendwie hundert Kilometer Abgründen, aber drüber eine Brücke ohne Geländer.
Das sind so die beiden Designprämissen. Alles ist alt und abgenutzt und wenn ich ein fucking eine Reling oder irgendwas in der Richtung sehe, schmeiss ich euch raus. Keine Geländer. Ja und keine Reissverschlüsse. Aber dann, ja stimmt, auch keine Reisverschlüsse, aber konsequenterweise wurde ja der Imperator besiegt durch einen Sturz von einer hohen Stelle. Nicht nur der, auch Darth Maul wurde ja in der Tat. Auch Darth Maul, Sturz, ja. Es ist ja nur konsequent, dass sich ja eigentlich in dieser Welt ohne Geländer, die Haupttodesursache sind Stürze ins Nichts, was natürlich auch ein großes Problem ist für die Familie, weil die Leiche ist nicht
zu bergen und es ist auch immer nicht klar, hängt der noch
irgendwo oder fällt der unendlich lange
durchs Universum mit verschiedenen
Orbits um
irgendwelche Sterne, weiss man nicht.
Was ein Riesenproblem ist, Bestattung in
Star Wars Welt ist eigentlich non-existent.
Ja, generell ist es ja der Verzicht,
um es grösser zu machen sogar, weil der Todesstern
wurde ja auch durch so einen dusseligen Bau hatpart am Ende letztlich für eine Abdeckung. Das heißt, am Ende sterben alle durch Verzicht auf, sagen wir mal, nötige Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. Ich habe das auch mal durchgerechnet mit dem Todesstern und das funktioniert nicht. War das ernst gemeint, ist der Typ ein genialitz witzler nein nein naja jedenfalls habe ich überlegt weil wir leben alle in grossstädten grossstadt smog autos rasen mit ihren schornsteinen durch die innenstadt alles qualmt alles ist voll frische luft ich will auch in der u-bahn frische luft haben und bei dune beim schenciaga-Star-Wars Dune, haben die ja diese, die Fremen draußen, die im Sand leben, haben diese geilen schwarzen Schläuche und dann dieses Geile, was man aus dem Krankenhaus kennt. Habe ich schon mal erzählt, hier habe ich mal vorgestellt, die, dann geht es so übers Ohr und geht der unter die Nase und da kommt dann Sauerstoff raus. und das kennt man ja dem krankenhaus ja ich weiß nicht genau warum sauerstoffsättigung im blut wahrscheinlich hoch zu bekommen oder sowas aber generell ist sauerstoff ja also hundertprozentiger sauerstoff macht er wahnsinnig wach auch und ist sehr gut und leute können vielleicht weiter rennen länger durch die stadt laufen und in der u-bahn hast du frische luft besser sitzen länger sitzen in der U-Bahn. Meine Idee wäre jetzt, man hat irgendwo eine Sauerstoffflasche und dann geht da so ein richtig schick, so ein kleiner schwarzer Schlauch so raus und dann gibt es so eine schicke Anbringung, Mechanismus unter die Nase und dann hast du da, kommt frischer Sauerstoff raus. Atmest du denn durch die Nase eigentlich? Weil ich glaube, bei mir würde da einfach überhaupt nichts ankommen. Ich atme, glaube ich, nie durch die Nase, oder? Du atmest nie durch die Nase? Ich bin nicht so der Nasenatmer, so ich bin eher der Mundatmer. Kann man das dann auch in den Mund nehmen? Also klar, das ist nicht der Anwendungsfall, der gedacht ist, aber kann man einfach zwischendrin sich das auch in den Mund, weil ich bin ja eher Richtung Taucher, dass du dann eher wie so eine Tauchmaske dann wirklich so einen Atmen hast. Wie bei Star Wars. Ja, aber warum atmet man manchmal durch die Nase, manchmal durch den Mund? Und warum gibt es nichts, was beides abdeckt, was so ein Mundstück ist, das auch noch Nasenabgänger hat? Gibt es ja, Stichwort Flugzeug. Gut, dann als Maske, ja, okay, stimmt. Stichwort Maske. Stichwort ganz Gesichtsmatrik. Aber ich finde das schön. Und ich glaube, man kriegt das gesellschaftliche, ästhetische Bewusstsein in die Richtung, dass es sogar cool aussähe. Also ich kann mir Innenstädte unironisch vorstellen, dass da Leute wirklich rumlaufen, so die Gen-Alpha oder wie jetzt die nächste Generation heisst, dass sie dann alle diese meine tize industries weiß nicht masken haben ich finde das eine gute idee aber ist das denn auch frische luft also wurde die dann auch irgendwie auf so eine kuhwiese oder so aufgesaugt dass man dann wirklich noch so einen hauch alpen flair noch mitkriegt die investoren fragen wie verdienen wir dann geld damit ja und dann meine antwort wäre abo-modell also diese man kann diese Diese Schluche, diesen Aufsatz recht billig kaufen, der sieht schick aus, aber den kannst du recht billig kaufen. Wir verdienen Geld über das Abo-Modell der Luft-Zylinder. Oder so kleine Patronen, die kannst du irgendwo dran machen, siehst du gar nicht. Und da kann man sagen, das ist immer bei solchen Ideen so, siehst du gar nicht. Aber tatsächlich faktisch um umgesetzt hast du einfach einen riesigen, schweren, so eine Glocke am Gürtel, das ja auch die ganze Zeit die Hose runterzieht den ganzen Tag. Das ist halt dann dieser Nebensatz, sieht man gar nicht. Und ich möchte dann da so, also Alpenluft. Da gibt es dann auch verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen. Im Grunde sind wir mit dem Vape ja relativ nah. Aber man muss natürlich noch selber nachziehen, aber wäre das nicht eine bessere Möglichkeit, dass man das so selber macht? Ja, oder ist es die nächste Generation Vape, dass du halt dauerhaft vapest einfach die ganze Zeit, dass du halt ständig das im Mund hast oder in der Nase und einfach durchgehend reingeht hast du dann so wunderschön so eine familienidülle
oder so ein popcorn oder so ein geruch popcorn wunderschönen erect
penis weil das auf den zigarettenbank steht immer drauf potenz
bedroht ja und auf meinem puren sauerstoff ist einfach so ein grosser
sie können weiterhin kind kriegen, ja.
Ja, genau, Pärchen beim Sex, sowas.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Einfach so Entwarnbilder, so einfach Entwarnung.
Entwarnung, es gibt nichts.
Finde ich gut.
Genau, fast als Gag gegenüber, also als Hommage an die Zierdenpackungen.
Oder einfach mal eine schöne, so eine Alpen, so ein Alpenidyll mit …
Kann gute Laune verursachen, sowas.
Ja, frische Luft.
Kann Entspannung verursachen.
Ja, finde ich super.
Finde ich eine gute Idee. Du kannst ja schon mal anfangen, es rein ästhetisch zu tragen, einfach als Nasenklemme.
Und dann kommt das ja langsam, dass es dann mit Inhalt gefüllt wird.
Aber hatte Dune denn den kulturellen Impact, den du dir gewünscht hast?
Weil ich hatte schon das Gefühl, das war ein großer Erfolg, aber aber es ist nicht so, dass es den riesen Impact hatte. Hättest du dir der Werk mehr gewünscht? Nee, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so möglich und ich glaube, es ist auch so intrinsisch im Material, weil ich glaube, das ist so dieses Abitur Star Wars. Oh. Nee, das ist eher so Studenten Star Wars, weil es ja streng genommen schon das Cleverere. Es ist komplexer und es ist auch tiefgründiger eigentlich. Jetzt ironischerweise als… Es hat ja niemand das Buch gelesen. Frank Herbert, genialer Denker ja auch vor allen Dingen. Aber jetzt wenn man mal Star Wars 1, 2 und 3 rauslässt, die politisch, glaube ich, das Komplexeste sind.
Also ich glaube, komplexer wurde Politik noch nie dargestellt im Mainstream-Film.
Ja, und langweiliger auch nicht.
Die Verhandlungen waren kurz.
Genau, also ich meine, aber Dune ist ja dahingehend schon nicht so reißerisch. Ne? Ich habe Dune 2 ehrlich gesagt noch nicht gesehen, muss ich sagen. Ich habe es noch nicht gesehen. Ich finde es super, ich habe es echt mit Spaß daran. Ich halte Danny Willner für den, ich weiß nicht, in unserer Zeit leben wahrscheinlich den besten Regisseur. Ist alles ganz, ganz toll, ist super atmosphärisch, super schick, aber also wenn du dann die Geschichte nacherzählst, dann kommt man ja auch an seine Grenzen. Also man erzählt jetzt nicht die grosse An seine Gedächtnisgrenze vor allem. Sondern es ist alles schon ein bisschen komplexer, man kann darüber lange diskutieren, aber es ist nicht so zufriedenstellend wie am Ende Hasseluk und er wendet die Macht an und er macht den Todesstern kaputt, das ist natürlich alles so ein bisschen greifbarer. Aber ich hab's mal durchgerechnet, Dune, und das würde nicht funktionieren. Ich hab's durchgerechnet und es funktioniert. Gut, vielleicht hat einer von uns beiden einen Fehler gemacht, definitiv. Das wird sich in hundert Jahren dann feststellen. Da wird dann vielleicht auch eine Podcast-Folge dann in die Kritik kommen, wo wir uns verrechnet haben, wo wir Nachkommastelle, Kommafehler irgendwie so, ah, ich mach leider oft den Fehler, so mit 15 zu rechnen, halt so ein Viertel von 100 sind 15, so weil ich an die Uhr denke, ich bin halt ein Zeit, ich bin halt ein Zeitmensch, so und deswegen denk ich mir so, ah, Hälfte von 100 sind 30, so und da ist einfach komplett, da bin ich einfach komplett dumm. Warum ist bei Uhren plötzlich sechs die Zahl? Ja, du kannst es fünfteln, ne? Hä? Du kannst es gut fünfteln. Kannst es zwölf nicht fünfteln. Aber 60 kannst du ja gut. Ja, gut. Und du kannst auch zehn gut fünfteln. Aber 100 kannst du halt nicht gut. Klar kannst du gut fünfteln. Nee, nee, dritteln, glaube ich. Es ging ums Dritteln. Warum willst du denn Uhrzeiten? Wann werden Uhrzezeiten gedritten? So hat mein Vater mir das erklärt, hat gesagt, das sind 60, damit man es gut dritteln. Wann werden Uhrzeiten, nimm mir ein Beispiel. 20 Minuten ist eine ikonische Zeit, 20 Minuten ist ein guter Zeitbereich, wo du sagst so, ich komme später nachher, ich bin so in 20 Minuten bei euch, so. Das ist eine gute Zahl, was du jetzt bei 100 nicht machst. Ich glaube, 15 Minuten werden häufiger gesagt als 20 Minuten. Angundert minuten machen soll ich komme nach ich will in 33,3333 minuten bei euch das funktioniert nicht so du musst 20 minuten ist eine gute zahl nein für die stunde reicht völlig aus und du kannst abschaffen als 20 minuten doch 20 minuten 20 minuten 20 minuten Ich sag ja immer, in Köln zum Beispiel, in Köln ist alles mit dem Fahrrad in 15 Minuten zu erreichen. Jetzt unter uns, das stimmt nicht. Manchmal sind es auch 20. Warum sagst du Dinge, die nicht stimmen? Naja, weil ich immer einen sage, ich will in Köln... Du sagst immer, ich sage immer und dann flüsterst du und sagst, das stimmt nicht. Warum sagst du denn immer? Ich will Leuten Köln verkaufen als eine schöne Fahrradstadt vor manche. Du doch nicht. Sag doch. Das ist doch die Wahrheit. Warum sagst du denn immer?
Ja gut, aber manchmal brauche ich auch zwölf Minuten nur.
Und sag fünfzehn. Aber ich würde eher fünfzehn sagen als zwanzig.
Ich finde, und du musst ja nicht
dritteln, zwangsläufig. Wenn es nicht geht, lass es.
Ich bin nur der Meinung,
mir stört, dass es halt diese
wir machen uns lustig, aber die Amerikaner
haha, benutzen imperiale System,
wie nervig, nichts geht zusammen, die, alle Einheiten greifen nicht ineinander, während wir immer mit Zehnern rechnen, mit dem Zehnersystem, ausser bei Uhren, zwölf. Ja gut, ich bin halt ein Zeitmensch, ich würde sagen, nee, dann lass uns alles auf 60 Polen so, und da kommen wir halt nicht zusammen. Das ist eine uncoolere Zahl, dass bei 60 Feierabend ist und dann geht man wieder bei eins los. 60 ist eine coole Zahl. Ich finde es eine richtig schreckliche Zahl. 60 ist eine fantastische Zahl. Ich mag 60 nicht. Warum magst du 60 nicht? Als Zahl. Warum, du kannst es sechsteln. Hast du mal versucht, die 100 zu sechsteln? Braun ist die Farbe, die Assoziation für 60. Nee, 60 ist so ein herrliches, 60 ist so ein herrliches Orange, 60 ist so ein herrliches, oh damit kannst du ja viel machen, damit kannst du einrichten, da kannst du Akzente setzen, aber auch eine Grundfarbe ganz gut, 60 ist eine herrliche Zahl, 60 ist eine wirklich gute Zahl. Ich glaube, wenn man die Lieblingszahl von allen Menschen aufschreibt und daraus den Durchschnitt bildet, ist es genau 60.
Hat keinen Wert mehr.
Doch, es ist einfach die Zahl der Menschheit.
Und wenn alle Menschen,. Das ist ja so das Ding, was ich immer noch nicht glaube, ist, dass wenn du so ein Glas hast mit Jelly Bellys, Cola, Sauerkirsch, Pfirsich, Kokosnuss, so alle verschiedenen Sorten, halt so Apfel, sauer Apfel oder Orange. Das ist ein buntes Glas, damit die Leute sich was vorstellen können. Du hast verschiedene Sachen drin, Schokolade, teilweise auch Mokka, die sehen sich recht ähnlich, aber sind vom Geschmack her unterschiedlich. Da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, du hast Zuckerwarte drin, du hast Limone mit drin, es und du brauchst es nicht. Limone mit drin. Aber auch so lustige Geschmacksrichtungen wie Popel oder so. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Nee, die nicht. Die gab es ja bei Jelly Belly nur im Rahmen von Harry Potter. Jelly Bellys. Mit Gringotts Bohnen. Die ist nie noch mal. Nein, nein, die ist nie noch mal. Betty Bots Bohnen. Mit sämtlichen Geschmacksrichtungen, ja. Aber, und das ist gut, dass du es ansprichst, weil genau diese nicht in diesem Glas, sondern da sind halt so eher die klassischen Sorgen drin. Ich glaube, Erdbeere gibt es auch, es gibt sowas wie Sahne, Sahne gibt es auch einzeln. Und da, wenn du eben ganz viele Leute fragst, schätzt, wie viele Leute heute das geschätzt haben, dann und die alle Antworten aufschreibst, dann kriegst du im Durchschnitt die richtige Antwort tatsächlich. Wie viele Leute... Das ist so schlecht erklärt. Du hast dieses Wunder der Mathematik schlecht erklärt. Ja, also ich zeige dir dieses Glas und sage, schätze, wie viele Leute wir gefragt haben, das zu schätzen. Welche Sorten da drin sind jetzt. Genau. Und dann sagen die, keine Ahnung, 20 oder so und es waren aber halt am Ende 50. Und im Durchschnitt, weil manche sagen zu viel, manche sagen zu wenig, im Durchschnitt, aber auch dafür müsste es ja gelten, weil wenn die Leute was schätzen müssen, die Gemeinschaftsmeinung ist richtig. Und das finde ich immer noch nicht glaubwürdig, nicht glaubwürdig, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil warum lösen wir nicht alle Probleme dadurch? Wie viele Sterne hat das Universum? Lass einfach alle Menschen schätzen und der Durchschnitt ist richtig, so das ist ja Quch. Ich glaube, es muss schon im Erfahrungsbereich des Menschen liegen. Weißt du, also ich glaube, man kann Menschen nicht bescheuert bei einem Glas, bei so einem Marmeladenglas voller Murmeln. Wer sind jetzt Murmeln? Ja genau, Glasmurmel, aber auch Plastikmurmel. Aber einer Grösse ist wichtig für das Experiment. Die haben alle die gleiche Grösse. Ja genau. Manche haben so ein gelbes, so ein Drehspiralding drin. Oh ja, wie werden die gemacht eigentlich? In Rot, geblasen tatsächlich. In Kugelform jeder einzelne? Ja, da musst du ewig lang für lernen. So und dann werden die geschätzt und dann wird anhand der Schätzung geguckt, wie viele Leute haben es geschätzt. Schätzen Sie, wie lange hat es gedauert, diese Murmel so in die perfekte Kugelform zu blasen? Und im Durchschnitt ist es richtig. Ich glaube das nicht. Man könnte sich viel zu viel sparen, wenn du sagst, irgendeine Wahl, dann sagst du, wie viele Leute haben für Trump gestimmt, warum zählen, warum nicht einfach alle Menschen es schätzen lassen. Warum wählen, warum wählen, alle schätzen lassen, wer gewinnt. Die Leute sollen ihre Stimmen abgeben und gleichzeitig schätzen, wie viele Stimmen der Kandidat bekommt. Und dann hast du am Wahltag musst du nicht die Stimmen zählen, sondern nur die Schätzungen zählen. Was genau die gleiche Arbeit ist. Und dann noch den Durchschnitt bilden. Mehr Arbeit ist. Und dann hast du das Ergebnis. Oder du musst nicht wählen, weil du kannst einfach zehn Leute schätzen lassen, wie viele Stimmen in diesem Topf für Trump sind. Auch nicht schlecht. In diesem Topf für Kamala Harris. Also ich finde es immer noch Quatsch. Das mag vielleicht für solche Gläser gelten, aber für viele ist andere nicht. Menschen kennen Gläser. Du hast den ganzen Tag mit Gläsern zu tun, du hast Sachen aus Gläsern getrunken, du hast schon mal was im Glas getan. Manche Gläser sind schwierig, weil die werden nach oben breiter, da kommt die Intuition so ein bisschen kaputt. In manchen Gläsern ist es eine Gläser. So Himbeeren sind ohne Hinden, wie viel Luft ist da noch zwischen den Himbeeren, das ist schwierig. Die Hannisbärder in manchen ist zum Beispiel aber auch Citrus. Ich konnte es wirklich nicht fassen. Also ich hatte diese Woche ein Erlebnis, wo ich mir dachte, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich hatte eine Flasche Eistee und das war so eine ganz merkwürdige Flaschenform, die unten so einen Bauch hatte und dann oben noch wie so ein Zwiebel-Turm. Orangine. Nein, und dann habe ich das aber halbiert. Also ich hatte zwei von diesen Flaschen, eine voll, eine leer. Und dann habe ich den Inhalt von der vollen zur Hälfte in die Leere gekippt, bis beide den gleichen Stand hatten. Warum? Das ist dein Nachmittag. Das ist ja auch gefreut drauf. Das war eine Aktion. Heute am Tag fülle ich die eine Hälfte in die andere Hälfte. Und dann habe ich so lange gefüllt, bis beide den gleichen Wasserstand hatten und es war so... Brauchst du nicht, weißt du, wie es gemacht ist, hättest du es machen können? Du machst einen Schlauch rein, dann saugst du an, machst du das andere und es wird genau gleich in sich die Level an. Das stimmt, ich hatte leider keinen Schlauch zu. Du hast ja immer einen Schlauch zur Hand, jetzt durch deine Nasenmaschine hast du ja immer einen Schlauch zur Hand. Also du kannst auch abstecken und dann den Schlauch für anderes nutzen. Ja, immer eine Erfindergarage. Ich habe so eine Rick-eske Erfindergarage und da liegen jetzt überall Schläuche drum, weil ich halt daran forsche. Du hast viel mit Flüssigkeiten zu tun, habe ich das Gefühl, ne? Ja. Und dann habe ich beide Eistees auf die gleiche Höhe gefüllt und ich konnte es nicht fassen, wie niedrig der Eisteestand war. Und ich dachte, irgendwas geht hier verloren, irgendwas geht hier verloren und ich habe es wieder umrum gefüllt, so wieder voll und ich habe mich wirklich gute 20 Minuten unterhalten, damit es immer wieder hin und her zu füllen. Weil in meinem Kopf ist immer so, wenn man das immer hin und her füllt, wird es weniger. Und ich weiß, dass es nicht stimmt. Aber in meinem Kopf denke ich mir immer, ich habe irgendwie. Naja, es geht schon was verloren. Wie denn? Naja, es ist schon mal was auf dem Tisch. Nee, ich kann gut füllen, glaub mir. Unten an der Wand.
Man hat ja manchmal so eine Art Bugs im Kopf, die man nicht rauskriegt.
Zum Beispiel denke ich immer, wenn du ein Blatt Papier hast und du schneidest es in zwei, ist es insgesamt weniger.
Ist die Summe der Teile weniger als ein Papier.
Genau, weil da geht was verloren durch Schneiden.
Aber das stimmt nicht.
Und auch bei diesem Eistätigen stimmt es auch nicht.
Was willst du beneinen? Dass da nichts fehlt. Ich glaube nicht, dass da was fehlt. Mikroskopisch klein schon was. Es ist nicht eine grosse Menge, die auch so herkräftig ist. Das wollte ich nur erzählen, witzige Anekdote aus dem Alltag, dass Eistee, dass der Füllhöhenstand von Eistee manchmal irreführend ist. Weil hätte ich das jetzt jemandem überreicht und hätte gesagt, oh, das ist die halbe Flasche, der hätte mir den Vogel gezeigt. Die Vorstellung, dass man unseren Podcast hört, weil was gerade in der Welt los ist, und dann hören Leute Podcasts und dann informieren sie sich und denken, welche Podcasts haben wir so am ehesten gerade, und dann hören sie bei uns rein und wir reden allen Ernst jetzt schon eine halbe Stunde darüber, wie Eistee-Füllstände unser Leben. Aber das führt mich halt auch wieder zu dem Eistee-Flasche halb voll, Eistee-Flasche halb leer. Und dann glaube ich, wenn du das jemandem überreichst und sagst, das ist die halbe Flasche, der sagt dann mal, du hast doch nicht mehr alle Eier im Karton. Also der ist ja wirklich außer sich, obwohl es tatsächlich so ist. Also ich möchte einfach im Kern die Intuition des Menschen angreifen. Ich sage, der Mensch ist Quatsch einfach in seinen Einschätzungen. Darum geht es letzten Endes rum. Das Experiment ist, du hast eine Flasche oder so ein Marmeladenglas, füllst das mit Murmeln und machst es zu, stellst es hin.
Ich glaube, du machst es nicht zu. Ich glaube, die sind offen.
Oder? Ich glaube, die sind offen.
Ich will es den Leuten
einmal erklären. Warum machst du es zu? Wir hängen uns an Details
auf. Okay, es kann auch offen
sein.
Ich will Marmeladenglas auch...
Obwohl dann hätte ich die Frage, ob jemand was rausnimmt.
Falsch. Ne, es darf niemand was...
Deswegen genau, mach es lieber zu.
Deswegen meine ich, mach es lieber zu und stell dir mal ein grösseres Marmeladenglas
vor.
Also stell dich mal so, es ist schwer zu erklären, so ein grösser.
Ich glaube, jeder einzelne Zuhörer hat komplett von vorne bis hinten verstanden, was los
ist.
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, dieses Bild, dieses, wir haben uns dann in den Gags verheddert, was, wie
wir erklären, was drin ist.
Man muss schätzen, wie viele, wie viele, sagen wir mal, halt, naja, was ist es, halt, wie viel Butter in dem, wie viel Butter ist in dem Glas, halt, wie viel Gramm, so, und dann ungefähr so, und dann wie viel Eistee, halt einfach, wie du es gehört hast, damals zum ersten Mal, Bohnen, ich glaubeölzer. Nee. Wie viele Streichhölzer sind im Glas? Du fragst, sag mal mal, 600.000 Menschen, wie viele Streichhölzer sind im Glas, die alle geben ihre Schätzung auf. Die trägst du ein in der Excel-Tabelle oder auf dem Zettel oder so. Ja, Flotin, du hättest die Details auf, die egal sind. Die können nicht miteinander reden. Das ist auch egal. Der eine der Erste, der geschätzt hat, kann nicht mit den anderen 599.000. Dirk. Dirk, so. Und der hat jetzt erstmal für den Rest des Experiments, darf der nicht mit den anderen reden. Ist denn wichtig, dass die alle aus einem Kulturkreis kommen? Stark. Weil jetzt kann ja der westliche Blick auf Streichhölzer ein anderer sein, als derernöstliche Blick zum Beispiel, weil jeder weiß, Streichhölzer sind da. Wie wertvoll sind Streichhölzer? Ja, sehr wertvoll.
Länger, grösser, oder nicht?
Kann auch sein, ja.
Kleine. So, deswegen meine ich, es ist Bohnen zum Beispiel. In einem Marmeladenglas, du zeigst es tausend Leuten, jeder gibt seine Schätzung ab und lustigerweise ist der Mediard, jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob das arithmetische Mittel oder wie der Durchschnitt berechnet wird. Wie viele Dinge kann man stolpern? Weil es gibt doch diesen einen Quatschdurchschnitt und den richtigen Durchschnitt. Ja, den Erwachsenendurchschnitt und den Kinderquatsch-Bullshit-Durchschnitt. Es gibt den durch die Anzahl der abgegebenen Stimmen berechnet Durchschnitt, dann gibt es das arithmetische Mittel. Niemand weiss es, niemand weiss es. Ist doch egal. Und der Durchschnitt der Schätzungen ist korrekt, ist nah an der Wahrheit dran, ja. Und da habe ich mal eine Kurzgeschichte drüber geschrieben, die habe ich dir auch mal geschickt. Weißt du das noch? Die hast du gelesen, du hast da sehr schön positiv darauf reagiert. Wirklich? Genau, wie dann daraufhin ausgehend auf diesem Gedankenexperiment die Zukunft berechnet wird. Und das ... Das muss aber schon lange her sein, oder?
Das muss schon lange her, ja. Okay. Aber das hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht, darüber nachzudenken, wenn man sich so vorstellt, dass wenn nur die Berechnungsgrundlage gut genug ist, kann man quasi etwas Unvorstellbares ausrechnen. Da habe ich mir das als Gedankenexperiment vorgenommen in einer zu fernen Zukunft, wo Computer die Zukunft berechnen können, weil, ja, keine Ahnung, wir als Menschen haben einen gewissen Erfahrungsschatz, gucken auf dieses Glas und den Bohnen und denken, ah, okay, so und so viele Bohnen sind da wahrscheinlich drin und das Mittel stimmt schon. Wenn du ganz viele Computer hast, die den Status quo der Welt checken können und dann so deterministisch ausrechnen können, wie das Bohnenglas die Zukunft, wie viele Bohnen drin sind, dann kommt man nahe dran. Ja, ich müsste jetzt die Kurzgeschichte nochmal lesen. Vielleicht kannst du die ja auch mal, hast du die veröffentlicht jemals? Nein, nicht Klett-Kot. 24,99, hast du dir mal angeboten? Diogenes, Surkamp, drunter mache ich es nicht. Apothekenrundschau, einfach so mal angeboten, mal wollt ihr das oder nicht? Hau dir mal raus. Frühwerke, Stefan Tietze Frühwerke und dann so ein Kinderfoto von dir, wie der irgendwie so mit einer Hand die Erde aus dem Blumentopf ist oder sowas. Stefan, die zu Frühwerke. Zu Frühwerke. Zu Frühwerke. Finde ich aber nicht schlecht. Dann kann man, glaube ich, dein Oeuvre auch besser in Kontext sehen. Jetzt finde ich aber generell ein schönes Buch. Zu Frühwerke. Und dann so der Quatsch von genialen Leuten. Ja, auch einfach um die zu erden. Der Bodensatz, so, was hat Goethe mit sechs Jahren für einen Schwachsinn? Für einen kompletten Bullshit geschrieben. Ah, okay, eine kleine Nachtmusik wurde von Mozart, da war er sechs Jahre alt, da hat er irgendwie morgen kommt der Weihnachtsmann sich zusammengereimt. Das will ich nicht wissen. Ich will, welcher, was hat Thomas Mann für einen Schwachsinn? Ja, worst of. Will ich einen lächerlichen Schwachsinn mit sechs Jahren fabriziert. Es ist wichtig, Leute in Kontext zu sehen, weil am Ende ist ja alles Schnitt. Es ist ja alles Schnitt. Du kannst jedes Leben so schneiden, dass der Mensch genial wirkt oder wie ein kompletter Dödel. Ich meine, deine besten drei Tweets gegen deine drei schlechtesten Tweets, das ist halt so ein komplett anderer Mensch. So, da würdest du gar nicht denken, dass die von derselben Person stammt. Ja, die Geschichte wird rückwärts erzählt. Die Geschichte wird rückwärts erzählt. Du, Dinge, die man sich gemerkt hat, werden wiederholt. Die coolen Dinge, die es wert sind zu erzählen, erzählt man. Und die Dinge, und deswegen wird alles rückblickend, es werden dann überleben nur die guten Storys. Es überlebt bei Thomas Mann ja nur der coole Scheiss, weil der wird sich immer wieder erzählt. Den ganzen Grotz, den er rechts und links gemacht hat. Lass mich dir kurz Zauberberg erzählen. Also, da war mal ... Die Buddenbrooks. Wo fange ich an? Es gab Thomas Buddenbrooks und es gab auch, sein Sohn ist auch Thomas Buddenbrooks. Also, genau, es ist so, so, also Michael ist der Neffe von, aber der hat ja, also damals war ja eine andere Zeit. Es geht ja um dieses Bremer. Und sein Sohn Lübeck und der Sohn heißt auch Thomas. Und da hast du ja, Handelz. Aber es ist erstmal egal, dann kommt Alois Permaneder in, ja, wo ist Bayern Großgrub. Es ist halt auch blöd, wenn dein Stamm halt einen nicht so talentierten Geschichtenerzähler hat, der einfach, der nur Bodenbrucks hat, wo du nur so, nur den intellektuellen Geschichtenerzähler so, können wir noch mal eine Gruselgeschichte hören? Ich hätte Effie Bries da und die Leiden des Jungwärters. Okay, ich gehe schon mal ins Bett. Ich lerne noch ein bisschen und dann gehe ich ins Bett. Ich habe neulich darüber nachgedacht, wie müde ich immer war als Kind. Ich war, weil ich erinnere mich an so Pfadfinderlager, wo ich dann so eingeschlafen bin als Erster am Lagerfeuer. Und dann wurde ich so geweckt, yeah, und dann hat der Pfadfinderleiter gesagt, kannst du aber schlafen gehen. Und ich so, okay, ich halte noch durch. Und dann wieder weggepennen. Dann gibt es diese Geschichte im Kindergarten, dass ich immer Mittagsschlaf gemacht habe und dann wurde die Kuschelecke gesperrt, weil Stefan drin schläft. Dann haben meine Eltern gesagt bekommen, ich soll noch ein Jahr länger im Kindergarten bleiben, weil ich die ganze Zeit schlafe, wirklich. Weil du den Lernstoff nicht mitbekommen hast, weil du erst verschlafen Lernstoff im Kindergarten nicht mitbekommen. Nee, ich habe so viel geschlafen, dann wurde mir nähergelegt, doch noch ein Jahr im Kindergarten zu bleiben. Was ist das denn? Ich würde sagen, der schläft den ganzen Tag, bringt den früher in die Schule. Der ist völlig gelangweilt von dem ganzen Kindergartenkram. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Und dann war es auch egal, dann gab es auch diese Stichtaggeschichte und da ist ja irgendwie Anfang August geboren, dann ist man irgendwie, hat man dann so einen Stichtag verpasst und so und deswegen.
Weil du geschlafen hast, hast du den Stichtag verpasst.
Ja, den Stichtag verpasst, den Stichtag verschlafen. Irgendwie weiss ich nicht, da gibt es widersprüchliche Aussagen, Fakt ist, bin ein Jahr später in die Schule gekommen, aber dann ja ja wieder habe ich ein Jahr eher Abi gemacht. Das heißt, am Ende kam ich plus minus null raus und war ein Jahr länger im Kindergarten, wo ich gepennt habe die ganze Zeit. Also wirklich absolut Jackpot. So, aber irgendwie zieht sich durch mein ganzes Leben und meine Eltern haben auch mal gesagt, dann wollten sie sonntags immer so, war so der Aktivitätentag. Da geht man in den Zoo, da geht man mal in den Wildpark, dann geht man mal zu einer Burg, man fährt zu einer Burg.
Ein Streichelzoo, Tiere, Tierpark, also du kannst verschiedene Sachen machen am Sonntag.
Ich wollte nur nicht nur sagen, dass wir immer im Zoo, im moralisch schwierigen Konstrukt Zoo waren, sondern wir waren noch in einem Wildpark.
Ah, die Seebären werden gleich wieder gepeitscht.
So, und da konnten wir häufig nichts mehr machen, weil ich so lange geschlafen habe. Sonntag. Das heißt, irgendwie zieht sich das so ein ganzes Leben. Ach so, die Eltern standen schon bereit im Auto, irgendwie mit dem Safari-Outfit, und Stefan schläft noch. Ja, meine Eltern waren nicht wilde Reiz, auf das jetzt so darzustellen. Ja, und dann war ich noch am Schlafen, und dann wollten die mich nicht wecken. Ach süss. Ist aber für Eltern, glaube ich, nicht so schlecht, wenn das Kind schläft. Also ich glaube, das ist schon ganz gut. Ja, aber dann haben die sich irgendwann mal an Ärzte gewandt und gefragt, sollen wir das Kind schlafen lassen oder wecken? Ich glaube, diese Diskussion gab es und ein Elternteil hat gesagt, Mensch, der Stefan, der schläft aber ganz schön viel, sollten wir nicht... Ich sag hier schon mal Stopp. Wir begeben uns hier auf ganz unsicheres Terrain. Der schläft, wir wecken ihn nicht. Man soll schlafende Stephans auch nicht wecken. Der schläft aus gutem Grund. Und je mehr der schläft, desto mehr Zeit haben wir für uns und für unser Privatleben, das wir jetzt 18 Jahre lang aufgeben mussten.
Und jetzt können wir endlich wieder ...
Was haben wir denn davor eigentlich immer gemacht?
Ich erinnere mich nur an die Zeit danach. Ich weiss nicht, was wir davor gemacht haben.
Nicht immer so einen Filmabend oder so? Ein Retspielabend?
Spielabend? Stefan, los geht's! Aber warst du denn auch lange wach und so? Hast du dann so lange wachgehalten? Nein. Du hast immer geschlafen einfach. So lächerlich viel geschlafen und es immer noch könnte ich, das meine ich ganz im Ernst, ich könnte 14, 15 Stunden schlafen. 16 Stunden am Tag. Könnte ich wirklich. Das kann doch nicht gesund sein. Dann wiederum habe ich ein bisschen reingelesen. Was viel schläft, gedeiht gut, sagt man ja. Ja, es gibt sehr viele Sprichwörter zum Schlafen, die sich alle widersprechen, nicht reimen, manche. Und ich weiß es nicht, jedenfalls habe ich gemerkt, ich finde es total schön, wenn Leute in meiner Umgebung sagen, boah, bin ich müde. Und ich merke das nicht,
weil ich, da habe ich so das Gefühl,
ah, ich habe die Person geschafft, ich habe es
irgendwie, weißt du, ich habe so,
ich habe für einen Tag gesorgt
oder was auch immer, wo die Person jetzt
gut schlafen kann. Ah, okay, ja.
Oder man, ich bin Freunde unterwegs und die sagen,
ah, jetzt bin ich müde und die mir so, ja, ich habe euch
Köln gezeigt, jetzt bist du müde, jetzt bist du ganz groggy und ich bin dann noch, weil ich war noch nie in dieser Position. Ich lieb das total. Also du schläfst viel, bist aber nicht müde. Nee. Weil du so viel schläfst. Nee, nee, doch, doch, doch, doch, das meine ich ja. Ich freue mich, wenn das passiert, weil ich immer müde bin. Ah, okay. Weil ich, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Ich glaube, weil meine Eltern mich haben immer schlafen lassen. Ja, ich finde auch, einer der schlimmsten Sätze ist, ich bin noch gar nicht müde bin okay weil ich ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht woran das liegt ich glaube weil meine Eltern mich haben immer schlafen lassen ja ich finde auch einer der schlimmsten Sätze ist ich bin noch gar nicht müde das ist wirklich so ganz ganz furchtbar so dass sofort Druck und Stress das wird immer in Gegenwart von sehr müden Menschen gesagt ja genau ich bin noch gar nicht müde ja genau das ist das Schlimmste ich dachte wir können jetzt alle nach Hause gehen und schlafen. Das ist wirklich so unter den Top Ten der schlimmsten Sachen, die man sagen kann. Ja. Also ich bin noch gar nicht müde. Auch so dieses, ich glaube, das ist genau was für dich. Ja. Das ist sofort trotz Reaktion. Wer meinst du? Ich habe letztens ein Album gehört und ich glaube, das ist genau was für dich. Und du weißt schon, egal was da jetzt für Klänge erschallen, ich werde sie ablehnen. Boah, das ist das Nervigste. Du kennst mich nicht, du weißt nicht, wer ich bin. Aber ich glaube, als ich das gehört habe, musste ich an dich denken. Das mag ich wiederum. Ja? Weil das sagt nicht, ah, es ist genau was für dich, sondern das finde ich einfach ein schönes Kompliment. Aber weißt du, was ich meine? Ja, ja. Aber ich verstehe genau, was genau, was du meinst mit es ist genau deins. Aber generell mag ich ja erst mal Kompliment, jemand denkt an einen, ist ja erst mal eine schöne Beziehung, aber dann oft fühlt man sich missverstanden. Und man will ja auch nicht in die Schublade reinpassen, man will ja dann auch der unverstehbare, mysteriöse Stefan sein, der plötzlich mit irgendeinem Album aus dem Argentinien der 60er kommt und da irgendwie Synthie-Pop aus den argentinischen Underground-Lokalen, so, das ist meine Musik. Und ich, ich habe da letztens was gehört, ich glaube, das ist genau was für dich, The Rolling Stones. Ja, ein Kumpel von mir hat mal auch als Autor geschrieben für so einen Arzi-Regisseur, und dann waren die alle bei dem abends mal zum Essen eingeladen, und es lief die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund so eine Arzi-Platte. Und zwar war das Baustellenlärm. Also das war eine Platte mit Baustellenlärm, und genauso muss man sich ja das vorstellen bei so einem Arzi-Typen. und es lief so richtig laut im Hintergrund und irgendwann war er dann der Einzige und es war wirklich so drei Stunden in den Abend hinein schon. Wie lang ist diese Platte? Die hat er auch lang gedreht, er zieht vorbei. Wirklich? Und niemand hat sich getraut, das anzusprechen, bis dann irgendwann der Kumpel gesagt hat, läuft ja die ganze Zeit Baustellenlärm, komm, diese Scheisse mal mal ausmachen. Und alle haben so gelacht, weil es fiel allen so ab. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist ja genial. Das ist brillant. Allein um, das ist so ein klassischer Diktatoren-Move. Wer hat den Mut, sich mir zu widersetzen? Und der wird sofort abgeführt. Der wird sofort abgeschossen. Getötet oder in eine bessere Position gehoben. Genau, ja. Es ist komplett unvorhersehbar, aber eins von beiden. Aber genau das macht es ja so interessant. Ich weiß, hier liegt gerade was im Raum. Traue ich mich es anzusprechen, was bin ich bereit? Aber Leute einzuladen, das war auch so eine krasse, hohe Decken, weird, ehemaliges besetztes Haus, Kram, problematische, also Riesenwohnungen mit so Stuck und so, und dann lief der ganze Zeit Baustellenwärm. Aber ich mag diese Figur, dieses Artsy Regisseurs, der dann irgendwie vielleicht auch davor dem Abend dann so total, scheiße, was soll ich machen? Ich habe hier Schwimmbadlärm, Baustellenlärm und dann habe ich die Autobahn. Ich glaube, das ist die Sinnliche für die Autobahn. Hanno, haben Sie sich schon für eine Platte entschieden? Nein, Sekunde, ich weiss nicht. Ich meine, der Robert kommt, der ist ja auch ein Formel-1-Fan, ich glaube Autobahnlärm.
Was macht der so? Okay.
Ich glaube, der ist eher so Autobahnlärm, aber irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Lotte, die hat ja früher auch als Lehrer. Wir haben Badlos Neunens reinbekommen. Das ist ein ganz fantastisches Album. Das ist wirklich jeder Track'n Hit. Wirklich? Und es läuft hier wirklich die ganze Zeit rauf und runter und wir kriegen immer wieder Nachfragen. Und jetzt haben wir eine Platte neu reinbekommenobahn baustellenlärm tatsächlich also ist es eine kollaboration ja genau richtig stark das ist eine geniale das passt ja perfekt zusammen ich glaube das ist genau was für robert man hört die fahrzeuge die die strasse aufbrechen ja dann teer du hast wirklich die ganze das ganze oeuvre die die ganze klaviatur an lärmenden Gegenständen und Fahrzeugen. Was, hat man Hupen drin? Man hat auch Hupen drin, natürlich. Leute, es ist heiß, Leute sind sauer, Baustelle, Geschwindigkeit, reduziert, zack, bebebebe. Geil, nehme ich. Das ist mal 58,90 Euro. Ja, gerne, aber so billig? Ich finde das schon gut. Das ist einfach ein Statement, so diese sozialen Hierarchien, dass jemand einfach sagen kann, ich kann es mir leisten, jetzt einfach die dümmste Musik aller Zeiten zu spielen und alle anderen müssen das ertragen und niemand widersetzt sich. Ja, das ist so eine Machtdemonstration. Das ist schon geil. Das ist auch so, ich bin der Regisseur des Projekts, auf dem ich arbeite. Und wir hören uns einfach Baustellen. So ist Sauron wahrscheinlich auch so. Sauron dann irgendwie in seinem Tour.
Sauron lädt nicht zum Dinner.
Sauron, doch klar. Dann die hohen Orks oder so, da die vielversprechenden, äh Meister, es gibt hier einen jungen Ork, der hat grosses Potential. ich wollte immer wo du das... Nicht so, wo du das sagst, wo du das mal anlässt. Ich wollte eh mal was Schönes, weil ich habe dieses neue Rezept gefunden. Ja. Ja. Elbchen. Ich schaue ja... Elbchen-Ragout. Ich schaue ja viel rum, also als Auge, und ich gucke mir ja auch viel von den Elben ab. So, weil, also ich meine... Wie ich vorstelle, dass das Auge dann so rumgeht in so ein riesen Kochbuch. Dahinter irgendwie so ein riesen aufgeschlagenes, riesiges Kochbuch. Und immer wenn ... So zwei A, zwei Teelöffel Salz. Und dann kurz irgendwie Frodo hinten, Auge hinten, Auge start, und dann wieder das Auge zurück. Zack, wieder zurück zum Risotto. Aber die Vorstellung ist, saure müde wird und abends immer das Auge zufällt. So, ab 19 Uhr wird das Auge auch immer ein bisschen kleiner. Er schaut noch auf so ein grosses Buch und langsam zwinkert er so und die Äuglein fallen zu. Und ganz Mordor schaut zu und dann so der Chef schläft. Ich finde es auch so geil, wenn man ganz Mittelerde immer sehen würde, weil er hatte diesen riesigen Scheinwerfer und jeder weiss, dass er gerade beobachtet, dass so die Elben sitzen gerade so beim Essen und dann so drauf und dann so was machen die da, Salat, Tiramisu und dann wieder woanders. Und er hat fertig gegessen und irgendwann hat noch ist noch was. Und dann sein
Auge so auf den vollen Keller.
Ja, Sauran, willst du
was davon haben? Ich schaff's nicht mehr.
Nee, nee, nee.
Schau so Schüchter wieder weg.
Schüchter in den Himmel und dann das Auge wieder
pfff. Was das für eine enorme
Strafe wäre, wenn
alle immer sehen würden, was du anschaust.
Also es gibt ja auch diese Eye-Tracking.
Dann wäre ich auch ein furchtbarer dunkler Herrscher.
Wie furchtbar wäre das denn? Stell dir mal vor eine U-Bahn, wo du könntest immer sehen, wer gerade wohin schaut. Das ist der absolute Horror.
Hier ist so eine hotte Orkfrau und dann fällt auf, dass Zauron ab und zu mal da hinguckt.
Wie unangenehm, ey.
Zaubern.
Was?
Meine Hörner sind hier oben.
Richtig unangenehm, ey.
Richtig unangenehm.
Das ist, ja, warum es keine, ich habe jetzt meine DVDs, ich hatte noch DVDs, die haben ein ganzes Fach in meinem Schrank eingenommen, habe ich jetzt, wie damals, als Argo liegen geblieben ist, habe ich die in den Karton gemacht und auf die Strasse gestellt. Alles weg, es war alles weg. Alles weg, wer hat denn diese, wer holt sich denn diese DVDs, die alten? Vor allem, jetzt habe ich rückblickend dann überlegt, weil danach habe ich noch gesucht und ich dachte, war es dabei, meine alte Musicalaufnahme. Nein! Und ich habe Angst, dass ich die auf die Strasse ... Wie heißt es, Schibolle? Nee, das sagen wir nicht. Doch, doch, das haben wir schon mal gesagt. Kismet. Kismet war es. Ähm, genau. Kismet, Stefan in der Hauptrolle und Kismet. Hadji. Ganz fantastisch. Boah, das war eins vor Blackfacing damals wahrscheinlich. Weil ein Haufen, die städtische Musikschule kam, führt Kismet auf. Ja. Alle spielen ... Eine Menge Selbstbräune. Irgendwie den Kalifen und so, alle spielen so Sachen. Boah, da ... Oh Gott, Stefan in Brownface, wie er in seiner Jugendschule singt. Wer auch immer diese DVD jetzt hat, ihr habt eine Menge Macht, ihr habt eine Menge Macht jetzt, ruft gerne mich direkt an und wir verhandeln eine Übergabe. Ich hätte das auf jeden Fall gerne. Es gibt keine Bilder, Gott sei Dank, wenn man das jetzt googelt, aber das war, haben wir nicht gemacht, bin ich mir sehr sicher, vor, bevor es so wirklich zum gesellschaftlichen Diskurs war, da habe ich, I dodged the bullet. Ja, so ganz kurz davor. Glück gehabt, Mensch, Glück gehabt. Mensch, ja, aber das ist wirklich so ein Humor, wo ich mir so Family Guy, weil das war nämlich genau das, was ich auch auf die Straße gestellt habe, die Family Guy-odien von Star Wars. Die habe ich mir irgendwann als DVD gekauft, ich fand die so lustig, alle drei Teile sind absolut genial und das hätte ich mir eigentlich jetzt von Herr der Ringe gewünscht. Sehr gut, ich meine jetzt bald kommt ja Rings of Power Season 2, ich weiß nicht, ob die einen humoristischen Einschlag jetzt nehmen, wäre unerwartet glaube ich so, dass die in Staffel 2 jetzt so komplett Comedy werden, aber vielleicht man weiß es ja nicht aber staffel eins war nicht so stark staffel eins war mittel bis schwach mit kurzen starken momenten sehr kurz flimmerhaft aufgeflimmerten kurzen starken momenten in einem sumpf der mittelmässigkeit sehr schlecht aber mal gucken wie staffel bei zwei staffel zwei weitergeht vielleicht das wünsche ich mir von dir bis nächstes fürs nächste Jahr. Sag die Dinge beim Namen. Es war scheiße. Nee, das möchte ich nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Aber das würde ich mir von dir wünschen. Sag doch, wie es ist. Nee, das möchte ich nicht sagen. Nee, das stimmt auch nicht. Nein? Nee. Aber bei mir ist es auch so, ich brauche nur ein paar gute Szenen pro Folge und ich bin zufrieden. Ja, das stimmt. Also ich glaube, es gibt Menschen, die haben, es gibt unterschiedlich gut-schlecht Verhältnisse. So manchmal höre ich Menschen, die sagen, der Film war so schlecht, weil es ja voll unlogisch, dass sie die Burg bei ... Das Birdman fliegt. Ja, das Birdman. So der braucht eine schlechte Sache und der ganze Film ist weg. Bei mir ist es andersrum. Ich brauche eine oder zwei gute Sachen und der Film ist gut und dafür bin ich auch gewillt, fünf oder bis zehn schlechte Sachen hinzunehmen. Ich habe, bei mir ist es eher gutlastig und bei anderen so, die haben zehn, können zehn gute Sachen aufsagen, aber eine Sache und dann ist der ganze Film. Ja, das ist Öl versus Celebration-Effekt. Ein Öltropfen kann, glaube ich, so eine Badewanne Wasser verunreinigen. Das wäre deine Leute, die sagen, ah, fuck, man fliegt, es gibt eine Miniszene, der Film ist mich ruiniert. Und bei dir wäre eher die Packung Celebrations, wo die wenigen Snickers auslösen, dass du die Packung Celebrations voller Mittelmässigkeit kauf. Und dann muss man sich auch durch Bounty durchkauen, aber ist okay, weil du hast die Augen auf die Snickers. Darv, was ist Darv? Ja, genau. Okay, verstehe. Werde ich in Zukunft benutzen. Öl gegen Celebrations-Packung.
Genau.
Ja, es ist eine gute Metapher auf jeden Fall. Wahnsinnig starke Metapher, also da ist nichts daran auszusetzen.
Richtig stark.
Ansonsten mal gucken, vielleicht machen wir ein Review, wenn die Staffel dann mal endlich läuft.
Und dann schauen wir mal, was wir dazu sagen.
Ansonsten haut rein, habt eine ganz schöne Woche.
Eine wundervolle Woche.
Geht mal raus, geht mal rein, geht mal raus und rein.
Ändert mal den Zustand eures Räumlichen.
Viel Spass und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wie immer, passt gut.